we're going to start in texas the other
team in texas the team in texas that has
a coach still
but is widely expected to not have a
coach
soon jerry jones stephen jones jason
garrett were due to meet for the third
time this week on thursday per multiple
reports the meeting didn't happen and
then things got a little bit weird on
thursday night ed werder of espn
reported this and this is what was in
the tweet we need to be very precise
here jerry jones and stephen jones have
moved slowly and with abundance of care
and respect for jason garrett that phase
expected to conclude soon with garrett
not part of the organization next phase
to involve candidate interviews will
begin quickly thereafter that's fine
that's fair and that's consistent
with
the
the expectations that anyone who's
paying attention to this
would have that it's expected that jason
garrett is going to be gone the only
hard news in there is that they're
moving slowly not because they don't
know what the hell they're doing but
because they are trying to show
extra care and respect to jason garrett
but somehow
that got warped and twisted into jason
garrett has been fired will be fired is
fired that still hasn't happened yet and
until it happens especially with this
cowboys team with how goofy it's been
the past five days i'm not going to
assume it's definitely 100 gonna happen
i agree it's expected but that doesn't
mean it's happened it doesn't mean it
will happen and until it happens i'm
going to sit back and wait for potential
chaos because of any team in the nfl big
cat the cowboys are the one that may
deliver it for us i don't understand
what's going on whatsoever mike why why
is this so hard for jerry jones to fire
jason garrett this is almost like
it's a terrible thing to say but it's
like you know when you get to the end of
a pet's life and you have to put down a
pet and it's like just have them hanging
around the house and doing the instagram
picture one last steak one last steak
with jason garrett one you know one last
ride one last ride in the car with jason
garrett what's going on what why are
they not just firing him
that's horrible no it's not i'm mike i'm
saying how ridiculous this has become
that's a special moment this shouldn't
be a special moment it should be hey
jason garrett thank you for your service
you were great it's time to move on
let's go about our business this is why
is it so difficult for them to fire
jason garrett i don't understand it mike
i really don't i guess it's i guess it's
respect for the position that uh jason
garrett was always a good soldier and
never fought back that's i think that's
really what it comes down to is jerry
jones is a little confused because he's
at times in the past has had an
adversarial relationship with his head
coach jason garrett is not that type of
head coach so he doesn't really know how
to act at the the last days of jason
garrett and you're right i actually
wouldn't be shocked mike if tomorrow or
sunday i've been saying all along that
jerry jones just waiting to do it during
wild card weekend so he can steal the
headlines but at some point in the next
few days if there's somehow a report
saying jason garrett's getting one more
year or he got a contract extension
would you be shocked i wouldn't no no
and and yesterday the speculation was
and ed werder who put out that tweet
last night yesterday morning his tweet
was there are people in the organization
who are beginning to wonder whether or
not the cowboys are trying to find a job
for jason garrett and i think that's
reasonable speculation see when the team
that is always open and transparent
about everything all of a sudden clams
up completely it invites speculation and
i don't think it was all that
unreasonable to say hey they must be
looking for something they can do to
keep this guy who's been part of the
family for decades
continuing to be part of the family and
i even went crazy off the charts
yesterday suggesting the possibility of
co-head coaches next year gary kubiak
and jason garrett and i was kind of
rooting for that i want unconventional i
want craziness i want something
different than what the other 31 teams
are doing because it's a good story and
it's fun to cover now i don't know how
fun it is to cover this silence coming
from dallas but it's definitely very
cowboys-esque for them to be giving us
something we didn't respect and look
that's all we're talking about you've
got vacancies in cleveland with the
giants with the panthers washington
introduced their new head coach
yesterday we ain't talking about any of
that we're talking about what the hell
are the cowboys doing cowboys win again
except on the field no it's true jerry
jones knows how to control the media he
knows how to make the cowboys relevant
even if they're not winning on the field
we're sitting here getting ready for
wild card weekend and the jason garrett
like firing unfiring conscious
uncoupling whatever is going on in
dallas it becomes a story and now we're
talking about it and so
i the whole thing i
jason garrett being in the front office
mike that's crazy to me could you
imagine if you're the new coach that
shows up and you have to you first thing
you do is meet the old coach who's still
there talk about an awkward situation
that is now more dysfunctional somehow
than it was before when it was just
jason garrett's the coach he's not a
good coach but we're going to keep him
as the coach this whole thing is just
hilarious to me and i'm rooting i'm with
you i'm rooting for chaos i want jerry
jones to coach the team why isn't jerry
jones just be the offensive coordinator
have jason garrett do all the you know
keep the sideline together jerry jones
you sit up in the booth you call the
plays and you know maybe chris christie
will be your defensive coordinator have
it be that let's just get let's just get
crazy with it in some seriousness though
don't sleep on the possibility of gary
kubiak that that name has just kind of
been percolating a little bit now he
left the broncos three years ago because
he couldn't be a full-time head coach
for health reasons but whether it's
jason garrett as co-head coach or jerry
jones and stephen jones running
interference with the media obligations
or having a robust coaching staff that
would allow gary kubiak to have a very
narrow and focused job don't rule out
the possibility of that kind of an
effort to kick start a team that is
ready to win you know there's been so
much talk about college coaches for the
cowboys job and it was about three weeks
ago that jerry jones threw water on that
by saying you're gonna have a learning
curve if you hire a college coach i
think they want somebody big cat who can
come in and win right now and someone
with nfl coaching experience is in a
better position to win now than someone
who's never coached in the nfl before
yeah i'd agree with that i i never
really understand
the hot name college coaches sure
there's a couple guys in college right
now that i could say you know what that
guy probably makes sense to eventually
end up in the nfl but i i've i've
thought at least the last decade it
doesn't feel like it was beforehand
remember back in the day when it was
truly you're good in college and then
you step up to the nfl i think a lot of
you know the recent hires come from nfl
staffs come from guys who have had that
uh you know who have been there been in
big games in nfl games and so to go hire
a college coach which is drastically
different running a college program than
running an nfl team that's why the urban
meyer talk i mean urban meyer is another
meyer actually be perfect in dallas
because they deserve each other jerry
jones and urban meyer both love
headlines let's just do that and make
the
the ultimate headline and have it being
be a walking talking circus every single
week
but see that's the thing jerry jones
doesn't want an urban meyer because an
urban meyer may not be comfortable with
jerry jones and stephen jones being the
focal point of the attention they need
to find another jason garrett maybe
that's one of the reasons why they are
taking so long to move on from jason
garrett they're appreciating that they
had a coach who let them do whatever the
hell they wanted to do all those years
and wasn't like a bill parcells or jimmy
johnson who wanted to take over go ahead
jerry do whatever you want i'm just the
coach and it's hard to find a guy who
you can trust to be a good head coach
who is willing to let someone else
basically hold the reins and and run the
wagon while you're just just a piece of
a broader machine and you know another
tweet edward had last night that i think
is intriguing he said he said this one
thing people should know regarding the
cowboys deliberate and confusing process
jerry and steven jones would not be
operating in this manner if they had any
indication they were risking head
coaching candidates they desire most to
other teams in other words all these
other names that are currently under
consideration for the giants panthers
and browns jobs those aren't names the
cowboys want i want to take it another
level farther i believe they already
know who they're going to hire
i think this this five days and counting
tells us they know exactly where this is
going to go when it moves on from jason
garrett now that doesn't mean they know
it's exactly one guy but maybe it's down
to one two or three but i think they
know where they're heading and they know
who they're going to get and it's just a
matter of checking boxes complying with
the rooney rule creating the impression
they're doing a real search even though
behind the curtain they know what's next
yeah that tweet makes a lot of sense and
it's a good point because the cowboys do
have the luxury of being the cowboys in
this sense where
it's going to be the number one job just
because of the national media exposure
being we talk about it with dak prescott
what's the implied value of being the
starting quarterback of the dallas
cowboys there is some and if you don't
if you don't at least acknowledge that
then you're just lying to yourself
because guess what as much as you know
the browns can win more games next year
than the cowboys but being the head
coach of the cowboys still means more
just in a national perspective you're
going to be on national tv more you're
gonna play sunday night football against
the eagles and giants three times a year
or whatever it is you're gonna be seen
more as the dallas cowboys head coach
mike i want to go back real quick though
to the idea that jerry jones the reason
why they're having so much trouble
finding the new guys they can't find
someone like jason garrett maybe that's
what happens maybe jason garrett goes up
in the front office he helps in the
coaching search they interview a bunch
of guys and then they sit around and
they have that moment where they're like
you know who would be great for this job
me jason garrett and then they just
rehired jason garrett i think that's
where this is all going
that's the thing until it's actually
done
everything has to be on the table
and everything is on the table i believe
i mean it is so strange to have an
organization that has been so open for
30 years shut up completely and give us
no indication of what's coming next and
and that takes a level of discipline
that i didn't think jerry jones had i
think i didn't think he could help
himself maybe he can help himself maybe
that's the big takeaway it all has been
a ruse he's been a carnival barker for
the last 30 years who's fully and
completely in control of his mouth and
when he chooses to shut up he can this
is just the first time in three decades
he's actually chosen to shut up
yeah it's crazy i mean the whole thing
is so crazy i i you know half time what
do you think half time of the wild card
game halftime maybe the sunday afternoon
game is when they'll when they'll
announce it so they can steal all the uh
maybe maybe jerry jones will come in in
like a uh he'll air drop in he'll
parachute into the philadelphia stadium
like fan man to the link yeah it's like
fan man and just be like hey i got my
new head coach let's go everyone talk
about that
i don't think they even have to do it
during any of the games they can show
respect to the games they can do it
after the game's end and it'll still be
the top story monday morning just like
it is as we're getting ready for four
playoff games we have spent the last 14
minutes talking about the dallas cowboys
vacancy that still isn't even officially
a vacancy yet
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports